hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to blank dream moving
right along
Mido ray oh that was it Mido Rado me
that was it that was the thing
Oh meto Rado me that was that was what I
did I don't know why I didn't get that
that was an odd connection I thought
that name was weird okay I want to meet
the smiling soul yes oh no come on now
yes I do yes I do yes I do yes I do
candies oh you're giving me this nice
stuff I'll take it thanks thanks dick
bag of [ __ ] all right whatever hello hi
how are you
the smiling soul yes that's me I am a
seeker of love a regular of the crack
smile dinner party oh but your face is
awfully stiff I can't look let's train
your smile a bit let's put a smile on
that face okay let's make things more
fun death is beautiful pain is pleasure
gratitude for sadness today we shall cut
up and boil a pig's heart oh oh it's
what I've always wanted
see it's getting more and more fun oh
not yet I'm afraid much too stiff come
on let's keep practicing
ah now let's make things more fun beds
or coffins life to the flame are those
legs if only all our blood could be
orange juice ow
see it's getting more and more fun whoa
Oh it seems to have loosened up a bit
but it's hard to call it a natural smile
once more oh yes once more please oh boy
now let's say make things more blank
bless it sterilize cubes of meat the
corner was yesterday I was hungry
therefore I bit off the pinky see blue
body getting more and more bleep well
barely Elsa for the crack smile dinner
party I suppose I just had a good idea I
make clear up your stiffness in one go
I don't think I should try it I'm kind
of curious so what's it what is very
simple this is always the best solution
for hard times
smiling soul turned the hammer to oh my
beautiful face I knew it was too much
okay all right be right back I knew
there was gonna be some bad whatever
whatever I just had to find out okay
all right gosh geez Oh flying them gone
Skippy Scooby Doo Dah skippity dippity
scooby doo doo da skate with the
identity scam DVD standard a nobody
Scapa dee doo dee I don't even know what
you're doing to my face anymore but I
don't like it okay that's enough thank
you I'm good I'm good ah very well don't
let your smile break or it'll make the
intend these uncomfortable okay oh oh no
did the pumpkin get him
I think the pumpkin mighta got him oh
okay oh okay
Bonjour me don't hit on me will you be
attending the crack smile dinner party
young madama I see a bit stiff but a
fine smile you have that warp smile is
perfect for this party go right ahead
man thanks Deary
I was happy Madame it seems one person
in the hall is an imitator who does not
have the right to attend lying with
their mouths their smile fake one who
does not truly enjoy the party if you
should find them you are free to do with
them as you please with them okay thank
you thank you sir the teddy bear stairs
with round eyes why not get elegant with
some wine and cheese a toast to the
fresh blood of Venus Oh gate smile
Mashiro felt deeply unpleasant good
pizza mainly features barbecue sauce and
some kind of meat barbecue pizza is
actually pretty good
I was trained by the smiling spirit
before coming the third round was tough
but now I can smile
Mashiro smile twitched smiling happiness
pleasure
we who gather here seek these things
unconditionally miss you know began to
feel strange cheese with the amount of
cutout on the table is a huge two layer
cake I think my smile might be breaking
Elizabeth that boiled fish meal wasn't
to my liking the sauces made it much too
sour
you're an imitator aren't you oh come on
I was trying to smile how am I supposed
to know who's the right ear guy is
alright fine then let's try it once more
Oh [ __ ]
okay all right fine I think it might
have been this guy smile deeply
unpleasant loose what was that pizza
again the meaty one it was quite
delectable yes I uh I don't like that
one the color and shape are hard to
describe it hasn't been touched yet oh
there's more sounding the range of
colors in these dishes feeling a little
sick now so I'm catching a breeze okay
wait what am I supposed to do how am i
how am I supposed to know I don't like
this
okay
find this world so unpleasant okay good
I think I'm reaching something here oh I
broke well what what am I supposed to do
then maybe if I try not smiling at
someone
you're an imitator like me huh then take
this I don't need it what's through the
door isn't something I'm after oh good I
braved the danger to come here but I was
off the mark now what to do okay oh that
girl's been sneaking around strangely is
she an imitator the crack smile dinner
party needs no imitators I'm hammering
for the only writer gasps oh crap
Oh boobie Oh boobie Oh boobie oh no oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no God
no no oh god damn it no oh god no no oh
god screaming does that help me okay
there we go
hmm there we are okay Hot Diggity damn
all right we got another mirror over
here the mirror shows mashiro's
reflection look in a little more tense
than I would have liked ten years ten
years ago holy crap that's a lot of
years ago wonder why hello am i but a
child I am a familiar place appeared
before mashiro's eyes Oh Monsieur on
still getting ready for your party so
wait here a little longer don't bother
your dad and grandpa too much okay gas
stove about to get used to its fullest
bye mom kitchen sink all comes with the
spray nozzle I wash your hands oh you
washed your hands without me telling you
make sure to dry them off what do i dry
them in the stove how do i dry them off
the lights are good
been a while since you've seen grandpa
huh you were so small then maybe you
don't remember be sure to say hi to him
I'm trying to oh I was talking to my dad
okay Mashiro you've gotten big it's me
your grandpa only saw you when you were
this little might as well be the first
you've seen of me turning six today once
you get into elementary you'll learn all
kinds of stuff
happy birthday okey-dokey then okay I
got tweezers why do I have tweezers why
do I need tweezers I said hi to Grandpa
now what oh I know what I knew just to
be clear dad today only I know that's
enough for me
for the rest you can do as you like
how's it going with your wife she's no
longer a new sweetie she won't have
anything to do with me now then how
about with Tamaki now she wants me to
contact her even if it involves money
nothing there's too much I want to say
but today is a happy day let's knock it
off from the Shiro's sake as you please
zero okay I know what I need to do I
don't want to
it's dangerous to insert any metal
especially if you happen to have wet
hands oh oh I get it now
boink okay I hope I got all the secrets
as if I was Egret I didn't yet I might
have done that a little early oh well
nothing to do now I might have missed
something I'm on of us something
important I have no idea I kind of want
to double-check that I say I'm gonna be
right back wait hang on sure came to she
felt her muscles stiffening there was no
sign of numbness in her limbs yes I was
an only child with three family members
my mom was chica my dad was Shinji and
on my sixth birthday my grandfather Enzo
came to visit it's a fairly distant
memory but somehow I feel like it that
was a really fun day good what did I
lose to get that back ooh what's that
it's a new key ball boy I love getting
new keys silver key okay
they still create
not cool bro hi cool Jesus god damn what
was I supposed to do oh man I was
gunning for it too
alright so that's a thing I need to
watch out for good okay go go go oh jeez
goddamn it looks like everyone else has
left the party good
what did she not like my performance for
her lock the door good what's in here I
wander the room is dark in the weak land
that doesn't seem to be able to lie to
that good adequate ok so I gotta come
back for that one good good for me oh so
happy oh I'm so happy
oh so happy so happy ok let's see if
there's anything new that I need to hear
over here hello deep in the realms ok so
young lady remembering a bit by bit ok
that seems to be all the new stuff so I
think I'm out of time for this episode
here so thank you everybody so much for
watching once again I hope you're
enjoying this one god damn that only got
me I wasn't expecting the doll so thank
you again everybody for watching check
out the other RPG horror maker games
that I played in the past below there in
the description down there in the
annotations over there thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
could you get